[Music]
it's Michelle of love muffin Beauty
science chem PhD cosmetic chemist and
sunscreen slapper honor it's time for
Asian sunscreen reviews some of these
I've been asked about a lot so it's kind
of a relief to get these reviews out
these are all Korean and Japanese
sunscreens that aren't approved in
Western countries like Australia except
for the last one which is actually a US
sunscreen what let's jump straight in
with today's sponsor skin 104. a lot of
you have probably heard of them but if
you haven't their sentella ampoule is
huge on Korean beauty apps you might
have also seen their zombie masks that
make it look like you've really overdone
it on those Tick-Tock skincare hacks
more recently you might have heard about
their cleansing oil and their water fit
Sun serum they actually have four
sunscreens in their range but this is
the one that I hear the most about and I
can understand why this is a really
lightweight chemical sunscreen it has
four of those newer filters that stay
more in the skin so surface so there's
less chance of irritation or potential
Health impacts they also absorb UV
better so sunscreens can have a lighter
texture while still giving really high
protection this is made by Colma who
made a lot of the really popular
sunscreens that came out in the last
couple of years and it is a similar
style of product it has that really
beautiful smooth moisturizer texture
that's just beautiful to apply and sits
nicely under makeup it Glides on really
smoothly like soft butter on your skin
bread this is even more lightweight than
the ones I've reviewed before like the
isn't tree and the beauty of chosen so
if you found those a bit heavy then
you'll probably like this one it dries
down to feel like almost nothing but
it's still giving that hydrating
slightly dewy finish there's no white
cast on medium skin tones and there
isn't any added fragrance in terms of
skin care actives it's got sentella and
a whole bunch of plant extracts
hyaluronic acid glycerin and niacinamide
it's approved as a brightening and
anti-wrinkle functional Cosmetic in
Korea all right packaging connoisseur
time I love this pump top you don't
really see a lot of pump tops in Asian
sunscreens but I am a huge fan of them
even when they're not twisty tops
they're twisty top
it just makes it so easy to apply a
consistent amount and you don't
accidentally just keep on applying less
and less over time without really
noticing also most importantly the pump
top is flat like the tube so it doesn't
actually take up extra space in my
makeup bag it looks round in a lot of
the product photos so I was actually
kind of confused when it came in like a
flat standard Korean sunscreen box I
thought maybe I was thinking of the
wrong product because I'm really
unobservant and that explains a lot of
things in my life I don't know why flat
pump tops aren't more of a thing this
just makes so much sense to me I also
tried out the tone brightening turnout
science room which has the same
packaging turnout sunscreens are a big
thing in Asia they basically leave a bit
of a white cast on your skin on purpose
to give a skin evening and brightening
effect it's like a tinted moisturizer
that's a little bit lighter than your
natural skin tone it's sort of like the
Asian equivalent of bronzer this has
mostly the same ingredient list as the
water fit sunscreen with extra titanium
dioxide as well as some moisturizing
ingredients it feels a little bit
heavier and richer but it's still pretty
lightweight I do not have a good history
with tone up sunscreens a lot of the
time they make my skin look weirdly pink
and detached from my neck it's sort of
like I'm having an allergic reaction but
this one is a lot more subtle it
actually did make my skin just look a
little bit nicer and smoother my skin
tone looks more even but it's still very
natural with no weird pinkness after it
dries down it takes about 15 minutes
though so I spent a lot of time staring
in the mirror going
um
because turnip sunscreens are
essentially tinted products you do have
to apply them pretty evenly this one is
pretty forgiving even for an unobservant
disaster like me sometimes I do get like
a subtle white line here but it Blends
out pretty easily without any pilling so
I am more open to turn up sunscreens now
I've been using this when I don't want
to go to the effort of putting on proper
makeup but I want my skin to look a bit
nicer and I have the time to let it
settle down and check for white masks
before anyone sees me the next sunscreen
is the Corsa Corsair Coast I'm sorry Sun
cut UV perfect Essence super waterproof
fun fact this Japanese megacorp that I
can't pronounce owns tarte now some cut
sunscreens are super popular and I've
been recommended this so many times if
you're buying Sun cut sunscreens be
really careful because a lot of them
have similar names and packaging so
there is a gel version of this where
it's also in a yellow tube and the only
difference in the name is that essence
is gel this is a fragrance free chemical
sunscreen with mostly newer filters it's
designed for outdoor use as you can
probably tell from the super waterproof
thing and the surfing goofy this is a
limited edition tube I have to admit I
partly ordered it because of the goofy
if you want to hook me in just put a
face on the packaging I probably won't
be able to throw it out because it'll
just look back at me out of the bin and
I'll just feel really sad and guilty
it's also resistant to sweat and
pollution it has a little bit of a goopy
texture and this nice water burst
cooling effect when you rub it in the
cooling comes from alcohol but I don't
think it has that much because it
doesn't really punch you in the nose
like some sunscreens do it doesn't sting
my eyes and I've seen a lot of people
say this doesn't bother their skin as
much as a lot of other sunscreens with
alcohol it's really hydrating with
ingredients like hyaluronic acid plant
extracts raw jelly extract and collagen
this is the one sunscreen in this video
that doesn't have niacinamide if you're
allergic to niacinamide you must be
having the worst time finding product
products so this one is probably worth
checking out I thought this would be
really shiny but it isn't after it dries
down it's actually quite matte and
smooth and lightweight and not tacky
there's no white cast but unfortunately
this does peel up on me it kind of balls
up in little tiny clear Sandy greens and
this happened when I applied it on Clean
Skin and also over products on the
bright side the pilling isn't very
visible but the fact that it is coming
off means that your sunscreen isn't
really having that intact film anymore
you're getting less protection from the
reviews I've seen it seems to really
depend on your skin there are lots of
people who say it doesn't pill on them
unless they're using the wrong products
underneath I'm guessing it's because I
have oily skin so it's just having a
conscious uncoupling with my skin oil it
probably works better if you have dry
skin I think this is one of those
sunscreens where if it doesn't ball up
on your skin then it's going to be one
of your favorites but I am not one of
cosei's chosen ones here is another
lightweight coma sunscreen it's the
Benton airfit UV defense Sun cream this
is pretty much exactly the same as the
beauty of chosen sunscreen they have
really similar ingredient lists and I
tested them side by side I could not
tell the difference between them in
terms of texture feel how they apply and
how they look on my skin the differences
are this has a minty scent that comes
from rosemary essential oil and it looks
green coming out of the tube I
originally thought this was giving a
cooling effect because it does say
cooling but then I tried the beauty of
chosen one and it felt exactly the same
going on so I think it's just the water
evaporating and maybe a bit of a
psychological effect with that minty
smell I was also hoping that the green
color would help neutralize some of the
redness on my skin but it doesn't I
think it's just too faint to make any
difference the skincare actors in This
have a sort of soothing calming theme it
has centella and licorice extract as
nice as this is it has a bunch of claims
that just make me feel a bit
first off they go on about how the
ingredients are ewg green grade which
means they're rated safe on the ewg's
very arbitrary made up scale if tonal
sunscreens are like here on my SAS
rankings then the ewg is like
yeah I do not like the ewg they say it's
free from octanoxate but then they don't
say what's so bad about octanoxate they
say it's free from silicos but then it
has two silicones right there in the
ingredients list the silicones are
probably a big reason why it feels so
nice and it looks so good under makeup
just please show some respect for the
silicones they say it's blue light
protection tested but they don't give
any details about us so it's been tested
but did it do well in the test like can
you share the results with us please I'm
not really seeing anything in the
ingredients list that's an obvious blue
light protector the other similar Colma
sunscreens don't have blue light claims
they also have this brand tagline that
says they make non-chemical products
which is obviously really silly because
everything is chemicals but especially
silly because this carefully says it has
organic UV filters but then on the
website it says it's a chemical
sunscreen I'm guessing they did that
because so many people ask them what
organic means is a chemical or physical
and they got sick of ants ring but then
they had to put chemical on the same
website where they say their products
are non-chemical price wise it's also
very similar to the beauty of chosen
sunscreen so I would just go for that
unless you're like allergic to rice this
sunscreen is a little bit different it
is glow recipes watermelon glow
niacinamide sunscreen yes before anyone
yells at me glow recipe is a US brand
but they have Korean American Founders
and they have like a very K Beauty Vibe
their products have lightweight textures
they've got a strong focus on hydration
this cute fruit theme they've also got
actors that are very popular in Korean
products like the one that starts with n
and ends in isinamide this launch was
really exciting to me because it's an
Asian style sunscreen that's actually
approved in the US and stopped in
Sephora so people in the US can actually
go and try the sunscreen before buying
it and not have to wait for shipping or
worry about fake products the downside
of a US sunscreen is that their
sunscreen ingredient options are a bit
needs Improvement so it was really great
to see glow recipe take on this
challenge of trying to make a US
approved sunscreen that actually feels
nice and lightweight I really really
wanted to like this but it did the one
thing that is like a complete deal
breaker for me it peeled up on my skin
pretty badly and the pilling was very
visible it was very like white and gray
this sunscreen does not peel on everyone
there are lots of people who love this
but it does seem to pull up on a good
portion of people I tried so hard to
make this work I tried it on bare skin
right after washing I tried it after 15
minutes after an hour then I saw on Tick
Tock someone say that it worked on their
skin after they moisturize it really
well so I tried it over six different
products with really different formulas
and
it didn't work so by that point I was
pretty depressed and I gave up every
time I tried it it was fine when I first
put it on but then after it's set after
maybe about five ten minutes if I even
brushed against it then it would pill
and you could really really see those
pills I don't know if it's like my skin
or the humidity here in Sydney or just
some other curse I'm sure there's some
product out there that would stop this
from pilling on me but I have not found
it and I am too sad to keep going I'm
also the sort of person who puts on
makeup right before leaving the house so
if a sunscreen pills a lot then it is
probably not going to work with my
extreme lifestyle otherwise this is
pretty nice it's not really as
lightweight as the Asian sunscreens I've
been trying but considering that it does
only use us filters I think they did
really well there was some white cast
but not as much as I expected for an
untinted sunscreen with 12 zinc oxide it
is a bit shiny but dewy skin is sort of
part of glow recipes brand and it is
actually quite hydrating which is pretty
impressive again there is 12 zinc in
this I love that they did this but I
would recommend trying a sample on your
own skin before buying the full tube
because who it pills on seems to be a
bit all over the place I hope you
enjoyed this let me know what else you
want me to try click the like And
subscribe to tell YouTube you want to
watch more of my videos and more reviews
are popping up around me